on va jouer aujourd'hui pour dire un
match donc il va pas voir un jour de
répit
allez on commence aujourd'hui
nos parents
pour les politiques qui veut mener
vous êtes perdus par exemple dans mon
secteur d'activité c'est 120 mille
suppressions d'emplois ces 10 milliards
d'euros de financements aux
collectivités territoriales au moulin
voilà c'est donc des services aux
usagers qui ferme c'est donc des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
c'est une rémunération qui va pas
augmenter l été le cas depuis 2010
voilà pour tout ça
c'est pas la même mobilisation va contre
des choses qui sont plus importantes que
seulement la loi travail je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
des questions qui vont bien au delà la
loi travail maintenant et c'est pas la
même dynamique c'est le dessin un point
de départ voilà donc ces modestes vous
voyez on va pas vous faire voir ton et 3
millions mais non c'est un point de
départ je pense que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut le voir au delà du fait qu'on ait
voté ou pas hier en l'occurrence enfin
pour mapou abstenu un vote blanc je
pense que l'idée c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui la question elle se
faisait avant mais elle est d'autant
plus urgente aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on
reste spectateur on va voter ou est ce
que on s'organise on se rejoint on
signifie on se bat et on les laisse pas
faire et puis on construit surtout un
autre monde quoi